bonsoir de retour sur le plateau du 7-8
à guyancourt après notre détour porte de
versailles à paris pour l'édition
spéciale salon de l'automobile year
edition que vous pouvez d'ailleurs
consulter sur notre site en replay
consultation libre bien entendu nous
sommes le 2 octobre
elle nous allons revenir sur l'actualité
locale au cours de la prochaine heure en
direct un jusqu'à 19h forcément premiers
invités jacquelot lloze bonsoir ancien
maire donc de magny les hameaux et puis
bertrand au lion qui lui est le nouveau
maire socialiste également de magny les
hameaux nous allons évoquer ce passage
de témoin entre vous c'était en fin de
semaine dernière jacques laurioz vous
n'êtes plus maire depuis quatre jours à
peine vous avez des regrets
nous regardons aucunement aucunement
comment se passe justement ce retrait un
petit peu là comment comment vous le
vivez maintenant que vous n'est plus
maire de la commune mais aussi vous
siégez toujours aux conseils municipaux
et non mais donc il ya donc des choses
encore à faire donc il ya une passation
donc normal donc à faire avec bertrand
donc il ya un travail non peu qu'il faut
qu'on puisse bien faire coïncider les
choses entre lui et moi pour qu'il y ait
pas de donc de quiproquos ça se passe
merveilleusement bien en tout cas pas
verrons comment ça va se passer
justement dans les prochains mois et
comment vous envisagez tous les deux et
plus particulièrement vous bertrand
guillon les prochaines échéances
municipales 2014 2005 2015 pour les
prochaines élections bourg soit anthony
salloum anthony rech le lundi le sport
et cette fois ci c'est le mardi c'est de
partir c'était le salon de l'automobile
ayant été aujourd'hui on va revenir donc
surtout les résultats sport du week end
oui et tout d'abord on va revenir sur le
bon début de saison des féminines
handball de montigny nous évoquerons
avec nos invités évidemment cette
actualité brûlante on peut pas y
échapper
parler va nous regarder comment on va
parler du land voilà exactement à lyon
de la faire des paris truqués notamment
nourou nous parlons aussi du
traditionnel parcourir ontinyent nous
reviendrons sur le 35e paris versailles
avec chine invitée pour le moins
inattendu je ne vous en dis pas plus
mais la surprise peut être très très
sympa et enfin évidemment les
traditionnels résultats du week-end
alors restez avec nous ce sera au cours
de la seconde partie de cette édition du
7 8 a tout à l'heure anthony on passe à
présent au titre de ce 2 octobre la
politique départementale du logement
peut être remise
cause c'est en tout cas ce que craignent
les représentants de l'établissement
public foncier des yvelines mobiliser
contre une menace de fermeture les
explications au cours de ce cette suite
à l'école de sainte thérèse inauguré l
encours par l'évêque quête de versailles
monseigneur aumônier nous nous
pencherons sur le financement de ces
établissements privés du sport aussi ce
soir vous l'avez entendu et cette
question l'herbe était plus verte à
maurepas en tout cas les terrains de
rugby ne plaise aux clubs nationaux le
stade français et le racing sont venus
disputer un match ce dimanche retour à
la compétition avec des anciens du sky
rugby avec club formateur qui évolue
maintenant dans ses équipes les joueuses
de tennis de table d'élan cours ont très
bien débuté la saison par une belle
victoire à saint denis 4 à 2 l'équipe 2
joue cette année son maintien principal
atout une bonne entente sur le terrain
mais aussi en dehors
reportage à suivre à l'école
sainte-thérèse a donc été inauguré ce
week end à elancourt un établissement
catholique sous contrat qui répond à la
forte demande des familles un chiffre
pour en témoigner 40 milles ils sont
plus de quarante mille élèves inscrits
dans le département à dépendre de
l'enseignement catholique et leur nombre
augmente chaque année présents lors de
l'inauguration patrick jacques de
dixmude et alice gastines font le point
c'est dans la vasque dans laquelle je
puiserai pour vous baigner revenir les
locaux c'est comme une bénédiction à
elancourt de la toute nouvelle école
privée sainte-thérèse après presque un
an de travaux elle peut désormais
accueillir douze professeurs et huit
classes de 206 élèves dont 85 et l'on
courtois bénir des locaux et surtout des
personnes qui vont y travailler
c'est cet insigne de qui a une relation
entre le créateur entre dieu et nous
dans les deux sens
coût de cette nouvelle école 3 millions
d'euros le financement de l'enseignement
catholique est assurée par les diocèses
et les familles seuls les coûts de
fonctionnement sont en partie financés
par les municipalités qui doivent verser
une somme correspondant au coût d'un
élève dans l'enseignement public
construire une école comme celle ci pour
nous c'est une certaine gageur et
effectivement nous ne pouvons pas
construire autant d'établissements qu'il
faudrait ou que les familles nous
réclame
notamment et en particulier il faut le
dire sur le département
nous avons des projets à l'heure
actuelle mais qui sont davantage des
projets de rénovation d'établissements
plutôt que de nouvelles constructions en
tant que tel pour les enfants ce qui
était difficile s'il y avait la même
cour pour les maternelles et les
primaires alors que la la cour et le
bâtiment maternelle est dissociée du
primaire l'école se trouvait auparavant
dans un centre aéré de la commune
quant au collège sainte thérèse qui
compte lui 362 élèves
il reste situé au mesnil saint denis
maire de 1983 à 1989 à nouveau élu en
1995 jacques lusa donc à démissionner
lors d'un conseil municipal exceptionnel
vendredi dernier à magny les hameaux
vous avez démissionné le 28 septembre se
déroulant au lion vous a donc succédé
c'était votre adjoint au logement vous
avez été élu on va revenir sur les
raisons de ce départ expliquez nous
pourquoi êtes vous parti et vous êtes en
bonne santé
voilà je tiens donc signalé ici son
plateau de télé fille que c'est en
parfaite santé
parce que donc le dernier reportage et
c'est croire qu'en sortant du
laboratoire que jamais un problème j'ai
eu pas mal de communication téléphonique
vous vous êtes gravement malade c'est
pour ça que vous partez ou quitter votre
poste
effectivement pour tous précisé pour les
téléspectateurs qui n'avait pas vu sur
un précédent reportage avec quelques
images d'illustration c'est comme ça
qu'on les appelle et sur ces images
illustration vous sortiez d'un
laboratoire mais ça n'avait rien à voir
avec votre état de santé
certainement voilà donc expliquer nous
les raisons de ce départ lui raison tout
simplement c'est que j'avais juste et
donc mondiale des mandats ensuite donc
c'est la question qui se pose est pour
moi c'est à quel moment donc donc arrêté
ma fonction
s'il fallait donc aller au bout du
mandat ou s il fallait s'arrêter avant
pour passer le témoin en était allé au
bout du mandat c'était une au pied en
quelque sorte
puis après on était sur des élections
avec n'ont que des inconnus j'éclaire
l'a donc 18 mois avant donc donc la
personne qui que j'ai proposé qui a été
validé par le conseil municipal limité
aux mille opposition qui était absente
curieusement c'était assez curieux donc
sur ce sujet là ils n'ont pas à 6 g lors
du conseil municipal roland cayre on va
dire ça manque de courtoisie et je crois
même que c'est là plutôt déplacé vous
avez préparé ce départ justement ce
passage de témoin les jeux les préparer
dans ma tête et je déposerai candidats
sur le dernier mandat chez s'allier je
savais la main de ma tête mais j'étais
le seul à le savoir puisque donc le ton
ce genre de chose il faut le faire donc
sur une séquence qui effectivement très
rythmé et en évitant effectivement donc
des temps morts donc je ça s'est passé
donc retour de vacances donc le début
septembre où la victime ont tout s'est
enchaîné je vais tout organisé en la
matière et donc pour certains c'est une
surprise pour d'autres donc c'est une
interrogation pour les électeurs c'est
une surprise puisque vous étiez le seul
à savoir vous allez passer la main bien
sûr on n'avait pas peur de leur réaction
électeurs nous ont l'impression qu'on
leur vole l'élection qu'on leur vole
leur mère pour lequel nous ont voté ce
sont les montpelliérains j'avais des
bouddhistes aimons et les mandats donc
s'arrêtait 18 mois avant
ce n'est pas donc sachant que je
continuais de cantine municipale quand
même temps donc j'accompagne
effectivement donc le nouveau maire dans
sa démarche avec les éléments qui sont
les miens avec mon expérience avec ans
que des sujets qui sont latents et qu'il
faut donc régler ça me semble tout à
fait logique et mais la problématique
c'est comme vous dites je les biens
gelés gelé bien préparé puisque 1
donc le samedi soir j'annonce a donc aux
associations donc les 300 personnes
ensuite donc le lundi un train qui sort
en france entre d'un communiqué explique
effectivement la démarche ont dix ans
quand je me considère comme un coureur
de fond qui doit passer le témoin qui
doit passer le relais et un court de
fonds ne passe pas à l'arrêt ils le
passent en pleine action en plein
mouvement attac et les électeurs ont
peut-être pas très préoccupée par ces
justement préoccupations de politique
politicienne parce que là on est dans la
réfute ce terme politicienne
certainement pas c'est donc donc une
démarche qui permet à manier d'un monde
de sauvegarde et donc ça j'ai donc son
mode de fonctionnement qui permet de
fonctionner au regard des son action et
sans rupture sans rupture et c'est très
important vous savez je vois comment ça
se passe ailleurs
quand effectivement il ya nommé à qui
s'installe qu'il est peu courante
touchera grosso modo maintenant il se
passe un an
bertrand vient justement vous arrivez
dans un contexte assez particulier comme
ça en cours de route c'est plus
difficile de devenir mère quand
lorsqu'on n'a pas été élu lorsqu'on n'a
pas mené la tête de liste lors de la
précédente c'est facilitant déjà je suis
élu depuis 1995
côté jack et c'est vrai que voilà ça a
été aussi une très longue période
d'apprentissage avec différentes
délégations du sport la vie associative
du logement seniors etc et en même temps
cet accompagnement cette volonté de
stabilité pour la continuité voilà c'est
un passage de témoin
assez assez lent pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir prendre toute la mesure des
choses donc c'est vraiment facilitant
après c'est vrai aussi
jacques l'oeil aux a été maire élu
depuis 77 sur la commune avec toute une
période de véritable transformation de
la commune on est passé d'une commune
qui était totalement sinistrée une
commune qui aujourd'hui vraiment envier
et c'est vrai que c'est aussi un défi
finalement de de prendre la de prendre
la succession
après tout tout ce travail accompli sur
la commune mais en même temps avec son
soutien derrière et puis avec une équipe
vraiment forte aussi est soudé il n'y a
pas de raison de paille arrivait
justement qu'en pensent les manies quoi
et lémanique ouest de ce bilan jack
l'odieuse nous leur avons posé la
question vous allez pouvoir les écouter
et puis leur répondre éventuellement je
trouve le bilan plutôt positif il a fait
pas mal de choses pour sa commune
pas mal d'un d'animation pour les jeunes
pour pour les enfants aussi dont ils
étaient les propos mauvais dans
l'ensemble il a fait pas mal de trucs
je pense qu'il a pas mal il a bien géré
un petit peu la commune il est enfin le
ya pas mal il a un petit peu rénové il
ya pas mal de choses qui ont été faites
donc je pense que globalement le bilan
est positif
ils étaient vraiment proches des gens
donc suis un peu déçu qu'il soit parti
mais bon c'est son choix mais pourquoi
il a fait cela c'est ça que je comprends
pas parce que lui on l'adorait quoi on
adore se magner franchement quoi ah ben
moi j'ai voté pour lui depuis toujours
ça résume c'est un micro trottoir
réalisé à un instant t
voilà et on est tombé sur des gens
forcément qui appréciez votre action on
l'entend du tout même une personne qui
s'interroge jean magny quoi qui
s'interroge pourquoi ce départ voilà le
le départ il nous l'avait expliqué oui
je vais expliquer c'est parce que c'est
vrai que c'est pas commun c'est vrai que
c'est pas commun les gens vont aboutit
donc à la fin de leur mandat et après
six nouvelles élections
donc c'est pas commun mais donc là en
fonction dition je peux avoir et donc
l'immense majorité des gens qui m'en
parlent ont compris et ont compris et on
compte que si l'intérêt de manier la
main et ont compris aussi que finalement
donc en 2014
quand bertrand se représentera aux
élections non seulement je le
soutiendrai puis chaque fois parti donc
du coup de soutien bien évidemment mais
en plus il aura déjà donc
asson à son actif un bilan qui dans la
succession de ce que j'ai engagées -
dans qu au début du mois d'été de 2008
c'est cela donc c'est une démarche ce
qui est tout à fait nouvelle mais qui
est donc le ton que assez rassurante
pour la commune de maniema ce serait de
l'intérêt de magny les hameaux pour vous
l'intérêt de magny les hameaux c'est de
ne surtout pas basculer à droite
certainement ces savoyards ruim donc
sauvé donc j'ai vécu cette période
énormément difficile donc de 77 ou
effectivement la commune étant en
faillite ont totalement au sous-préfet
de l'époque monsieur disait que non que
mais il a moins été lavé retourner
rebondissements vous rendez compte et
que donc la période aussi donc donc 89
95 oui monsieur rivalier qui a été élu
si aujourd'hui dans l'opposition qui
vous avait exigé naissant 83-82 vous
ayez joué
il avait donc sachez quand même pour
donner rapidement compte que le résultat
à la fin de son mandat
deux des agents ont présenté contre lui
donc on voit bien un peu l'état d'esprit
qui régnait dans cette équipe équipe
autres guillemets donc et aussi ce qui
s'est fait oui aussi ce qu'il a fait et
opposition que magistrat qui avait des
habitants par rapport à ses projets
notamment la prothèse à coeur de ville
bertrand oui on revient quelques jours
en arrière le soir de votre élection
avec ce reportage de johanna sonnerie
patrick jacques de dixmude conseil
municipal particulier une page de
l'histoire de notre commune se tourne
après 35 ans de dévouement
jacques lozach choisi de permettre le
renouvellement dans la stabilité et la
continuité
bertrand au lion a été élu maire de
magny les hameaux lors d'un conseil
municipal exceptionnel vendredi 28
septembre après quatre mandats jacques
lolliot a décidé de démissionner pour
laisser sa place à un ancien
maire-adjoint
pour moi il était important que donc
on puisse passer donc à une autre
génération de quelqu'un qui avait
effectivement donc la bonne connaissance
de la ville et parce que donc être mère
donc vous savez ces six en six ans c'est
court et ses longs la fois si on veut
réaliser il faut donc s'orienter
parce que c'est comme ça il faut
s'orienter sur voir au minimum deux
mandats donc bertrand refuge en âge 36
ans et il est en capacité de pouvoir
poursuivre victimes en cette activité si
effectivement les maillys quoi mais y
croit du lohn confiance chaque le lieu
ne démissionne pas pour des problèmes de
santé mais afin de préparer des
prochaines élections municipales en mars
2014 bertrand ou lyon sera le candidat
de gauche
les 18 mois à venir vont être 18 mois de
travail de continuité
finalement cette élection on pourrait
dire que c'est tout simplement la
continuité de notre action
on n'a pas de changement autre que les
personnes au niveau de l'exécutif et on
continue notre programme avec toujours
le même enthousiasme toujours la même
disponibilité de l'ensemble de
l'ensemble de notre équipe majoritaire
du conseil municipal parmi les dossiers
au programme celui de la réhabilitation
par l'opievoy des logements du quartier
du buisson
mais aussi la continuité des
circulations douces le nouveau maire
s'engage à défendre les services publics
et notamment la poste qui menace de
supprimer le service de tri et de
distribution sur la ville lors de ce
conseil exceptionnel bertron lyon invite
endossé son rôle de mère pour remettre
la médaille d'or de la ville à jacno
lloze ou delà de l'émotion de la gauche
l'absence de l'opposition s'est fait
remarqué aucun des cinq conseillers
municipaux de l'opposition n'étaient
présents vendredi soir
qu'est ce que ça veut dire c'est ça la
démocratie c'est ça la démocratie
tant que donc il ya une convocation du
conseil municipal pour élire le nouveau
maire est donc ces gens donc le dépose
complètement ça veut dire que finalement
il n'accepte pas finalement qu'il y ait
une majorité donc au niveau d'un côté
musical il n'accepte pas qu'il puisse y
avoir des changements
un déni de démocratie à son tour évoqué
par le collectif mène une nouvelle
énergie dans un communiqué manille
nouvelle énergie collectif visant au
renouveau politique de magny les hameaux
dénonce un véritable déni de démocratie
et rappel à jacques l'eau lloze bertrand
guillon et l'ensemble de l'actuelle
majorité de gauche que les seuls qui
trancheront seront les manies quoi et
manic oise en mars 2014 lors des
élections municipales
outre le maire un nouvel adjoint a été
élu à l'urbanisme et au logement
j'entends seraient les deux venus de 8e
adjoint de bertrand au lion du nouveau
maire de magny les hameaux
bertrand guillon par rapport à ce
collectif justement manie nouvelle
énergie qui est menée notamment par des
élus par des élus en tout cas les
responsables de l'ump
quand on parle de déni de démocratie
j'accueille aux masses la mare au cours
de mandat votre thèse c'est une totale
méconnaissance de nos institutions déjà
puisque il faut savoir que le maire est
élu au suffrage indirect par le conseil
municipal
donc c'est le choix du conseil municipal
après le passage de témoin en cours de
route
et justement de la part de jacques los
dioses déjà un acte de courage parce que
c'est
c'est très rare que d ébut déjà bien
établie dans leurs fonctions choisissent
de passer la main à une nouvelle
génération
et puis
et puis à côté de ça le fait qu'ils
soient absents ce soir là finalement me
fait un peu penser à un électeur qui
n'irait pas voter et qui a une guerre
qui va s'engager sur cette commune de
magny les hameaux en mars 2014 pour ces
élections municipales comment ça va se
passer on a l'impression du côté de la
droite aussi se prépare que du côté de
la gauche sont là bien entendu en tout
cas vous vous préparez ça c'est sûr il
ya un vrai enjeu autour de cette commune
d'un sachant que la commune et dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin si
cette commune la bascule et que ça
restait en l'état
l'agglomération passerait à droite pour
nous c'est simple forcément tête ça pour
nous c'est simple je le disais dès le
soir de l'élection mais on le disait
déjà avant on a un programme qui a été
présenté aux manies croisé omani qu en
2008 qu'on continue d'appliquer
on travaille d'arrache-pied pour pouvoir
faire avancer notre commune pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir amener le mieux vivre
ensemble sur notre commune avec
l'ensemble des acteurs de la commune que
ce soit les associations et des
habitants
on continue sur cette démarche 2014 sera
une étape parce que forcément on se
représente devant les électeurs on leur
présentera le bilan qu'on a établi
et puis on leur présentera aussi la
suite des choses et le programme qu'on
souhaite
après 2014 mais voilà c'est une étape et
nous on continue sur notre ligne de
conduite qui est de travailler pour
manier la moue et pour ses habitants
c'est à dire que là vous allez continuer
justement c'est la question je vous pose
à travailler pour magny les hameaux vous
êtes uniquement dans l'optique de 2014
parce que ça va être difficile de
prendre des décisions de faire des choix
d'arbitrer période on a des choses qui
continuent aujourd'hui une salle de
festivités qui ont cours de route par
exemple
l'évolution sur l'agriculture de
proximité qui est en route également les
circulations et des rénovations de
voiries qui sont en route également ce
qui était déjà prévu avant justement
c'est des choses qui était déjà prévu
qu'on continue et qu'on continuera 2000
2014 est une étape mais une étape
logique dans nos institutions qui me
fait absolument pas peur et qui nous
fait pas peur
donc sur laquelle on se mettra pas
forcément de pression de pression
particulière
en face à priori je sais qu'il ya
certaines velléités mais qui viennent se
présenter puis c'est ça le jeu
démocratique justement moi je les
sereinement par contre il est clair que
ben nous on siège qu'elle avait changé
elle sera votre façon de faire quelle
sera la pâte bertrand au lion sur
pouvait parler de parler sa curieuse
quel sera l'impact père trognon qu'est
ce qui va changer la pâte bertreau
millions sera la continuité de la pète
de jacquelot limbs très bien on va voir
justement ce que pensent les manifs quoi
on les entendu parler certains manient
cohade de votre bilan
que pense-t-il de vous est-ce qu'il vous
connaissent aussi leur réponse je pense
que c'est une bonne chose pour la ville
passé c'est un enfant de la ville et
c'est la suite de monsieur l'oeil aux je
pense donc il connaît bien les dossiers
de la vie donc je pense que c'est une
bonne bonne élection si le jeune et qui
connaît bien la ville ouais pourquoi pas
fin ça peut être une bonne chose s'il a
ses proches des gens tout ça marche
parce qu'elle y pas mal parce que je
connais pas personnellement mais il est
très sympa c'est bien si
il est jeune il a l'air très attentif à
sa ville donc que tu souhaites bon
mandat quoi c'est quelqu'un de sérieux
quand même
c'est je pense qui fera son boulot quoi
au même titre que monsieur law lloze
c'est une personne qui de manière
réellement qui est déclinée sur manille
et qui entreprit la politique de retrait
enfin un âge assez assez restreint qui
attend à 14 ans il était déjà engagée
puis voilà donc je suis je suis content
parce que je sais que c'est une personne
humaine responsable puis qui est prête à
travailler valeur bertrand voyons
nouveau maire de magny les hameaux 36
ans vous avez toujours vécu à magny les
hameaux président du conseil municipal
des jeunes en 90 également conseiller
municipal depuis 1995 maire adjoint
depuis 2001
vous travaillez à côté je travaille à
côté vous avez arrêté que vous allez
arrêter non la politique n'est pas un
métier et est encore plus travailler à
côté et pour moi vraiment une nécessité
pour pas être décrochés des des
véritables réalité et les réalités
finalement tous les habitants peuvent
peuvent peuvent connaître et par contre
voilà j'ai la chance d'avoir un
employeur qui me permet de consigner
l'ensemble et rsa permet d'avoir un
aménagement de mon temps de travail pour
pouvoir accomplir l'ensemble de ma tâche
votre profession je travaille à la
communication la fédération française de
cyclotourisme
on saura tout ça c'est compatible de
travailler en même temps que d'être mère
je les fais moi donc il faut
effectivement s'arranger pour un peu de
temps donc permettront aussi au travail
à temps complet donc
dans son emprise donc sa puce l'autre en
transport ça paraît très difficile
d'autant que la fonction de maire
aujourd'hui donc n'est pas celle qu'on
connaissait il ya 30 40 ans c'est pas du
tout la même chose et en même temps je
veux revenir quand même sur le ce qui a
été dit par l'opposition déni de justice
non c'est la démocratie donc je réfute
ce genre de choses est effectivement ce
terme utilisé cette absence constatée
sont vraiment révélateur de l'état
d'esprit donc de cette opposition très
particulière ici à manier les mots je
vous dire quand même que dans que deux
jours avant je t'ai donc je suis vice
président des maires du canton de
chevreuse je suis le seul maire de
gauche et donc donc en partant donc ils
ont tenu à me faire un cadeau et m'ont
dit non que sur tout donc si tu le
suggères pouvait faire la même chose que
toi
ce serait fabuleux donc c'est vrai qu'il
reconnaisse que manier les mots l'a bien
senti
vous êtes déjà en campagne vous préparez
déjà 2014 alors on précise aussi mon
jeune âge je dise le chemin après être
tombé à monter les spectateurs que
jacques rivaillé donc qui mène
l'opposition sur la ville de magna mots
nous avons cherché à le joindre nous
n'avons pas réussi à le contacter mais
ce sera bien évidemment bienvenue sur ce
plateau pour pour s'exprimer
un conseil peut-être à donner pour
conclure cette séquence un conseil à
donner au nouveau maire de magny les
hameaux sauver donc un conseil il écoute
donc le sérieux et en même temps utile
de faire ce qu'on dit et avant de
conclure cette séquence je vous propose
tout même de découvrir un autre sujet et
concerne l'établissement public foncier
des yvelines un organisme public qui
peut réaliser ou faire réaliser des
acquisitions foncières et les opérations
immobilières et foncières de nature à
faciliter l'aménagement ultérieur des
terrains ça peut paraître assez
compliqué mais c'est très important pour
les communes
on va regarder ce reportage puisque cet
organisme pourrait disparaître et vous
pourrez réagir ensuite à ce reportage
branle bas de combat au sein de
l'établissement public foncier des
yvelines il s'estime menacé la semaine
dernière un amendement a été présenté à
l'assemblée nationale avec en premier
alinéa ce qui sonne comme une douche
froide
il ne peut exister qu'un seul
établissement foncier de l'état par
région or en ile de france il existe un
établissement régional et des antennes
départementales dont une dans les
yvelines pour le président conseiller
général fermer cet établissement dans le
rôle est de conseiller voire de
cautionner les communes dans la
réalisation de logements
c'est tout simplement un frein à la
politique de construction depuis 2006
120 conventions ont été signées dans le
département et cela représente en termes
de potentialités de logements
parfaitement identifiés et répertoriés
sur ces conventions une potentialité de
35 mille logements
la grosse particularité de
l'établissement public foncier des
yvelines c'est de travailler avec toutes
les collectivités
même sur des petits projets à peu près
20% pas plus des dossiers que nous
traitons sont du niveau de ceux qui sont
traitées au niveau de l'agencé de 80 qui
ne serait pas n'aurait jamais vu le jour
pour les conseillers généraux
socialistes cette inquiétude n'a pas
lieu d'être
l'espi est un outil qui a fait ses
preuves mais ce débat se doit de poser
une autre question en quelques jours
encore une pose question que très vite
on se place plutôt la vraie
problématique celle qu'il vaut mieux
avoir une bonne coordination entre deux
niveaux départemental et le niveau
régional en un mot tout cela à mon sens
qu'une tempête en verdure une tempête
dans un verre d'eau
les salariés de l'établissement public
foncier des yvelines en seront plus le 4
octobre lors de la réunion de la
commission mixte paritaire
si la fermeture devait intervenir cela
se ferait dans les 18 mois donc l'avenir
de cet organisme public qui est qui est
menacée même s'il faudra encore attendre
avant d'en savoir un peu plus cet
organisme véritablement important pour
les communes vous le sollicitez par
exemple sens magny les hameaux pour les
réalisations vous n'êtes pas déjà solide
nous pas particulièrement puisque on a
donc des terrains qui appartiennent à la
casse qui donc cote donc lorsque
l'opération d'une nouvelle c'est terminé
on a racheté les terrains pour éviter la
coloration met donc pour l'ensemble des
communes qui doit effectivement que le
relogement faire des équipes d'enquêté
si dramatique puisque les terrains donc
sont monopolisés par le privé qui font
effectivement monter les prix donc à des
ventes et qui empêchent la réalisation
de jeunes et notamment du logement
social
merci jacques losay est revenu sur ce
plateau pour la première fois en tant
qu'ancien maire de manière moins fumer
resserre bertrand guillon qui était
avancé le maire pour la première fois
votre première sortie officielle ce sera
quoi en dehors de ce plateau
la première sortie officielle a déjà eu
lieu j'ai visité la gendarmerie de magny
les hameaux samedi dernier c'était la
deuxième sortie merci à tous les deux